738 billion dollars that is the massive
size of the inflation reduction act with
it the Biden Administration in the
United States wants to among other
things boost the production of electric
cars and batteries now Brussels says
those benefits for U.S car makers put
their European competitors at an unfair
disadvantage
U.S President Joe Biden is on a
last-minute campaign tour in heavily
contested districts trying to head off
Democratic losses in Tuesday's midterm
elections he talks about the issue most
on voters Minds inflation we also know
folks are still struggling with
inflation it's our number one priority
that's why with Mike self and Scott's
help I signed an inflation reduction act
to bring down the cost of everyday
things that we talk about around the
kitchen table
but the ACT is Raising eyebrows in
Europe and Asia because it includes a
seven thousand five hundred dollar tax
credit for Americans who buy an electric
or hybrid vehicle but only when it rolls
out of a North American Factory with
domestic batteries
it's no problem for Tesla GM or Ford but
it's a big problem for manufacturers
like Toyota Hyundai and BMW the German
car maker has eight electric and Hybrid
models but only the two it makes in
North America qualify for the tax credit
next year
like cars made here in its Spartanburg
South Carolina plant
but not the ones it makes in Europe
it's America First at its worst critics
say
the American inflation reduction Act is
a matter of concern not only for France
and Germany but also for All European
countries so we need to work on the
adequate European responses to this
American inflation reduction act which
might jeopardize the developing field
between our two continents
European officials threatened to take
retaliatory measures against the United
States on Monday calling the subsidies
contrary to World Trade Organization
rules
to avoid a tit-for-tat trade War
Brussels and Washington have set up a
task force to try to hammer out a
solution
for more than for more on this let's
bring in DW correspondent Jack parekh
and Brussels and Simona Mena she's the
president of the American Chamber of
Commerce in Germany welcome to both of
you Simona let me start with you a
massive subsidy program that might cause
European manufacturers to lose out on a
growing market now your people should be
up in arms
well I I would be not so alarmed because
there are talks and I think uh the act
as such has a good purpose but maybe
there were some mistakes in how it was
finally formulated so correction would
be necessary but not now a war
Jack let me cross over you to Brussels
uh the French economy Minister Bruno
Lamar says Europe's industrial future is
at risk here that does sound quite
concerned how worried are you officials
yeah they are pretty worried we've
actually got a meeting of ministers
Finance Ministers of the the EU here in
Brussels today and we've had some pretty
strong comments valdostomrovskis who's
the sort of European commission's trade
chief he was talking about these as
discriminatory Provisions yesterday we
heard Christian Lindner the German
Finance Minister talking about the
potential for a trade War the language
is very very strong around this issue
the Europeans are really really worried
about what this means In the Heat of the
midterm elections the Biden
Administration is very keen to show
they're doing everything they can to try
and reduce inflation but that's also a
concern for European ministers and
European governments as well who's who
are seeing inflation Skyrocket in the
Eurozone and all across the European
Union as well so they're making quite
strong statements at the moment but what
it looks like and what we've heard from
uh the treasury in in the U.S Janet
Yellen pretty much saying that they're
not going to change this that the
inflation reduction act in the US is
there to stay a so leaders in Europe are
concerned Simona back to you
um what does this mean then for your
German member companies that are doing
business uh in the United States and
hoping to prosper there in a in a
growing Market
of course our German members want to
prosper and to and be part of the
transatlantic trade and that is what the
U.S what the American Chamber of
Commerce is for transatlantic trade so
what we need is good agreements that we
have a mutual partnership that we have a
transatlantic sovereignty and not
protectionism on the other hand I think
the wording which the political leaders
use at the moment are very very strong
and it's not necessary there is a trade
and a technical
technique and trade Council there is the
G20 Summit these are good locations to
talk about and look for Corrections and
not immediately talk about war or
counter action because that would not
help anybody so not our members not the
U.S companies and not neither the us nor
Germany so Simone in brief terms what
are the mistakes that need to be
corrected from your point of view
well I think it's very important that we
look at the protectionism which is well
for batteries for example or also for
hydrogen and you you should think about
biontech Pfizer so good cooperation
between Europe and the US can prosper
both so don't close and that is what the
inflation reduction act does don't close
out European Innovation don't close out
European production and on the other
hand we like to have U.S Innovation U.S
technology here in Europe it would be
very bad for both sides if we now make a
barrier between the two of us
head of the American Chamber of Commerce
in Germany and Jack parrick our
correspondent in Brussels thanks to both
of you